[Music]
[Applause]
jason mccord is back with us zooming in
with us nfl network good morning
football co-host there you look good you
look like you're ready to play uh could
you do two days during the week and your
brother do three days and nobody would
know the difference
yeah the toughest thing is we'd have to
talk about contract because he's getting
paid a lot more than i
if we're gonna we're gonna alternate
he's gonna have to give me a little bit
more of those millions of dollars he's
making how often does
the topic of identical twins come up
conversation for you
uh a lot um especially when we were both
playing football the comparisons um he
was in new england from uh all of his
career majority of my career spent a
year in cleveland didn't win much eight
years in tennessee never made the
playoffs so the twin stuff has followed
us in our entire lives that i don't see
that changing anytime soon does your
brother rub in the championships into
your face i mean how does that work with
brothers
he can now i got my one super bowl ring
i told him i don't need three yeah
i was able to get there i tell them all
the time
it was me coming to the team in 2018
that's helped him secure his third
champion
[Music]
uh 13 years one sack
what do you remember about
it uh my uh corner coach in new england
gave me a hard time about that we were
trying to find a way to let me blitz uh
because my first sack came early in my
career uh versus jacksonville it was it
was a strip sack at that
we didn't recover the fumble but a
glorious moment for me i was never able
uh to do again so once that david
gerrard
no it wasn't i believe it was chad henny
if i'm not mistaken it wasn't it wasn't
gerard well he's not that hard to bring
down
yeah i'm not going to give myself too
much credit it wasn't that it wasn't
that impressive of a sack i was
unblocked coming off the edge
more of a scheme thing than a tablet
thing um
what do you think players think of the
kyler murray situation because it's one
thing for us to have something to say
about it you guys are the guys who sign
these contracts you're going to be in
the locker room with the quarterback
uh what do you think the feeling is with
that the language in a contract with
cottamer
yeah i think it's twofold i think uh for
those guys in our locker room there
might be guys in the locker room that
don't like tyler and maybe they think
he's lazy or doesn't do this or doesn't
do that those guys in that locker room
which i was so majority of that locker
room uh where they probably love them
and i don't think this was probably news
to anyone i think it's probably more
shocking that it's in the news and now
it's uh a distraction almost in a sense
i think if i was in a locker room that's
what i would be most annoyed by as as
the start of training camps rolling
around that may be a guy who just signed
or a guy that's kind of on the bubble
i'm trying to make the team and i may be
a veteran i'm getting interviewed and i
keep having to answer questions about
kyla murray's contract a guy who's
making a quarter billion dollars who's
obviously performed well enough that the
team decided to pay him despite of his
amount of film wash or anything like
that so i think within a locker room you
understand that hey we may all be
treated fairly but we're not all going
to be treated the same i played with
guys throughout my career who could go
out all week still show up for practice
every single day and perform well on
sundays
maybe i can knock them i think the
biggest thing is for them is going to be
trying to figure out how to get kyle
murray to perform better uh down the
stretch of the season for himself and
arizona cardinals but were you aware on
the teams you were on how much time the
quarterback was putting in
nah never aware um i think you always
knew that quarterbacks were coming in
early on mondays
there all day for the most part on
tuesdays as the install was going in
because i mean let's face it mentally
that's probably the hardest position on
the football field
yeah i'm wondering how he handles this
because
it has the potential to be embarrassing
because they're they're saying look
you're not putting in the time maybe or
you're lazy
yeah
it has to be annoying and i think um
like i think you said that's part of the
reason maybe they did it maybe they
thought it would reflect battle and he'd
now all of a sudden start to do more but
i mean he could literally go home turn
on the video games
grab his ipad
open up the film hit play leave it over
there let it play for an hour while he's
playing call of duty so to me is more of
a
ploy within the media to hold him
accountable for the rest of the
interested people in the world opposed
to him actually watching film and who
knows how much time does he spend in the
building maybe he watches all of his
film inside the building and he wants
some me time uh when he kicks back and
it's probably beautiful arizona home
well i understand that you bring up a
great point i think there's not gonna be
somebody there at home monitoring him if
they're gonna go hey we're watching what
you're watching on your ipad all right
click i'm watching and you're playing
world of warcraft um and but i i wonder
though how much of this is on cliff
kingsbury he's the head coach he's a
former quarterback
don't you usually have a veteran who
helps the younger quarterback understand
how to prepare
for an opponent week in and week out
that's what i mean i'm kind of baffled
by this
i mean we talked about it throughout the
nfl the whole time i was in playing in
the league veteran leadership and how
important it is uh i can look back i had
cortland fan again chris holt those were
guys that taught me how to be a pro
there's one thing to have a guy that
said hey for tyler hey when this thing
opens up you're gonna have a hot reading
you're gonna hit your ex receiver
backside but it's another thing having a
guy in a meeting room day in and day out
of showing you what it's like to prepare
for a game and i think
it does fall on the head coach of being
able to make sure hey each and every
week he's prepared and he's already said
that he's a guy that more goes off his
cognitive skills he doesn't need to
watch a ton of film we talked about on
the show today uh michael vick at one
point said earlier on in his career like
he didn't really see the significance
said he'd get the little dvds and just
throw him in the back of the car and
obviously before he got into trouble
with everything michael vick an electric
player who was having a really good
career so i think there's levels to it
does tyler want to be one of the best
quarterbacks in the league does he want
to win the championship those are the
things that we'll see over time how much
work he's willing to put in to see how
high he wants to take it and sometimes
you're so gifted that you haven't had to
put in the time it's just natural but
that's why i keep bringing up michael
vick vick said if i put in the time i'd
probably have a super bowl ring this is
coming from vic who might be the most
talented player who's ever played that
position
you played against kylo murray um what
was the game plan i think 2020 uh you
guys played against him
yeah we wanted to keep him inside the
pocket that was the biggest thing we
were going against and we wanted to
force him
obviously a smaller quarterback but
extremely electric when he got out on
the edge and he had the ability to make
guys miss to be able to make plays in
space and just kind of be able to be
creative uh in the moment he makes it
very challenging uh for defense so for
us we wanted to keep him bottled in and
keep him in the pocket and then be able
to disguise and mix up our looks and
he's going to continue to see a lot of
that when you're as good as he is on his
feet teams aren't going to want to let
you beat them that way so they're going
to try to force you to stay in the
pocket and be able to disguise things
for any young quarterback that's the
hardest thing of being able to read
those coverages
who was the quarterback that you faced
he went damn he's a step ahead of us
oh my goodness peyton manning he was
just
tough i remember we played him i was in
tennessee uh when he got to denver and
he was so tough with when you tried to
substitute or you're trying to huddle
he'd go straight to the line call
another play so going into the game we
had a system where we wore wristbands we
gave numbers within
the first drive we threw that out the
window on our db coaches on the sideline
just signaling every call
we let them we gave up 50 some points
that game and knew a guy on the other
team he was like yeah after the first
quarter uh between peyton and the guys
upstairs they knew all of you guys hand
signals so they were just feeding them
what the coverage was going to be in wow
we gave up 50 points so peyton was
always a step ahead what if you just
didn't listen to what he said at the
line of scrimmage would that have been
better if you're trying to figure out
what he's saying because a lot of it's
you know just you know garbage a decoy
i remember when i first got to tennessee
obviously indy was in a division we
played them twice a year and when it
came indie week like everything shifted
in the building and we get like a little
packet that had all of the things and
sayings and signals and stuff over the
years uh that peyton manning and that
offense was doing and i remember my
rookie year we had some injuries i ended
up starting that game obviously we lost
but i'm looking through the pack and i'm
just like there's no way in hell i'm
gonna remember these things when i get
out on the field there's about a hundred
of them so yeah throw it out all
there's no way that you're going to be
able to use that
when you were uh you got to the patriots
brady famously loves to come up and say
hi i'm tom brady that's as if you
wouldn't know him when you got there did
brady do that to you
i already had that moment uh i used to
travel down to all the super bowl so i
remember it was maybe dev's second year
in the league uh when they went to the
super bowl in indianapolis and i'm there
with all the families and all of that
and he comes up to me i was like hey man
i'm tom brady man love watching you play
for me i'm in my second year i remember
telling everybody you know brady just
came up to me and said he knows who i am
but tom and tom was awesome a great guy
to share a locker room with extremely
humble down to earth man great just
great not only a great player but a
great person uh tyree kills putting a
little pressure on your former
quarterback there in miami in tua what
do you think of that game plan
yeah uh i think we talked about that
this morning if i'm too uh i'm loving it
you know it's that it's that new
girlfriend phase you got that
infatuation everybody's fired up about
it and i think when you look about look
for tua throughout his career when he
first gets to miami ryan fitzpatrick's
there and the questions are hey should
we hand it over to him but hey
fitzpatrick's doing well then two it
kind of takes over later on but there
was question marks hey should it still
be fitzpatrick and then you look at last
year tulas comes in he's the starting
quarterback all throughout training camp
hey are they going to trade for deshawn
watson hey stephen ross and ownership
they want desean watson and the trade
deadlines the same story so even from
talking to him last year like that
becomes frustrating no guy wants to hear
that continue to look over the shoulder
so i think
yes he's probably a little bit over the
top there's a compliment every week
about to the most accurate pass in the
nfl now but i think it's nice to have
some positive vibes going on around that
building uh moving into this season this
year
hey congrats on the new gig and uh we
appreciate your time thank you
oh appreciate you thanks for having me
that's uh jason mccourty he's now with
good morning football